La muerte de Yevgeny Prigozhin ha supuesto
un antes y un después para el Grupo Wagner.
El fallido motín del pasado mes de junio
fue fatal para su destino.
Al líder del grupo de mercenarios más famoso
desde las pelis de Sylvester Stallone le perdieron
sus ambiciones de poder y se metió con el
tipo equivocado: Vladimir Putin.
El Kremlin marca mucho y ser el heredero de
gobernantes como Simeón el Soberbio e Iván
el Terrible debe de ser una enorme fuente
de atrevimiento y ego personal.
El actual zar de Rusia e invasor del este
de Ucrania ha reunido méritos más que suficientes
como para ser recordado como Vladímir el
Vengativo.
La factura de Prigozhin por su particular
marcha sobre Moscú ya ha sido pagada.
Sin embargo, queridos amigos, todavía quedan
muchas preguntas sin respuesta respecto al
futuro del Grupo Wagner.
Han perdido a su rostro visible, pero aún
hay miles de mercenarios desplegados por diversos
países, especialmente en África.
Pues bien, superada la conmoción inicial,
parece que comienza a aclararse el panorama
a la vista de titulares como este:
(Compañías militares privadas rusas se disponen
a hacerse cargo de los combatientes de Wagner.
WSJ)
Todo indica que el Kremlin tiene mucho interés
en que los logros de Wagner en África se
mantengan.
Para ello es probable que otros grupos de
mercenarios con notables vínculos con el
Ministerio de Defensa ruso y con los cuerpos
de inteligencia rusos pasen a controlar buena
parte del imperio formado hasta ahora por
Wagner.
Ya se sabe el dicho: para el vencedor, el
botín.
Y también ese otro que dice: “El muerto
al hoyo y el vivo al bollo”.
Ahora bien, esperad un momento, amigos, porque
hay un grupo de irreductibles mercenarios
rusos que no quieren dejarse dominar y están
dispuestos a pelear por la supervivencia de
Wagner.
Por eso, la pregunta es: ¿Qué va a pasar
a partir de ahora con el grupo Wagner?
¿Cómo intentará mantener el Kremlin los
múltiples beneficios que las actividades
de Wagner ofrecen a la política exterior
de Rusia?
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a dar respuesta
a estas preguntas, pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de Historia.
T1 (EL MÉTODO WAGNER)
Todo comenzó en Ucrania hace casi 10 años.
El rastro de Wagner nos lleva hasta marzo
de 2014, cuando Rusia se anexionó la península
de Crimea.
Aquello fue diferente a la actual invasión
de Ucrania.
En aquel momento en Crimea salieron de repente
de la nada los famosos hombrecitos verdes.
Hablamos de soldados sin insignias ni distintivos
que el Kremlin nos quiso hacer creer que eran
una especie de hombres del bosque simpatizantes
de la causa rusa, civiles que habían tomado
las armas en este territorio a orillas del
Mar Negro porque querían dejar de ser de
Ucrania y unirse a la Federación Rusa.
Por supuesto, la realidad era muy diferente.
Aquellos "pequeños hombres verdes" eran una
mezcla de algunos agentes de las Fuerzas de
Operaciones Especiales y otras unidades del
servicio de inteligencia militar de las Fuerzas
Armadas Rusas, junto con personal contratado
del Grupo Wagner.
En otras palabras, una mezcla de espías y
mercenarios.
Justo lo que el Kremlin necesitaba para negar
que los hombrecitos verdes estaban allí cumpliendo
directamente sus órdenes.
(La Constitución rusa prohíbe la creación
de destacamentos armados de carácter privado.
Pero en el Kremlin siempre fueron conscientes
de sus enormes beneficios.
La negación verosímil es una de las grandes
ventajas que ofrece contar con compañías
militares privadas a tu servicio.
Da la oportunidad de intervenir allí donde
los Estados no pueden actuar oficialmente.
Y luego las autoridades siempre pueden negar
la implicación del Estado en las acciones
de estos mercenarios, especialmente en aquellas
que tienen un marcado carácter clandestino.
Y, además, las bajas no cuentan.)
Por supuesto, la ley nunca fue un obstáculo.
En el Kremlin solo necesitaban a alguien que
no tuviera problemas en saltársela.
Un oligarca que actuara en las sombras.
Que proporcionara una fachada empresarial
aparentemente legal para una actividad completamente
ilegal.
Alguien dispuesto a seguir la receta facilitada
desde los despachos donde se cocinan este
tipo de asuntos.
Y como decimos en VisualPolitik: dicho y hecho.
Su hombre era Yevgeny Prigozhin, el chef de
Putin, dueño del restaurante favorito del
presidente ruso.
El rastro del grupo Wagner post-Crimea volvió
a aparecer en el Donbass y en Siria.
(Los mercenarios de Prigozhin jugaron un papel
destacado en la guerra separatista del Donbass
que estalló después de la anexión de Crimea.
Asimismo, a finales de 2015 surgieron informaciones
de la participación de mercenarios rusos
en la guerra de Siria en apoyo del régimen
de Bashar al-Assad.
Fue la primera vez que el grupo Wagner utilizó
la fórmula de servicios militares a cambio
de recursos naturales.
En este caso, a cambio de un 25% de los ingresos
de los campos de producción de petróleo
y gas recuperados al Estado Islámico.)
Sin embargo, queridos amigos, África ha sido
con mucha diferencia el continente en el que
más se afinó el método Wagner.
Después de su éxito en Ucrania y Siria,
la diplomacia rusa comenzó a ofrecer los
servicios de sus compañías militares privadas
en sus tratos con otros países, siendo el
grupo Wagner su mejor exponente.
Su primer trabajo en África fue en la guerra
de Libia, donde el Grupo Wagner ha estado
al servicio del general rebelde Khalifa Haftar.
Los mercenarios rusos proporcionaron más
equipos, capacitación y servicios de inteligencia
a las tropas de Haftar a cambio de acceso
al gas y petróleo libios.
(En los últimos años, el Grupo Wagner se
expandió por una docena de países africanos
con un modelo de negocio que tiene básicamente
tres elementos.
El militar, ofreciendo a sus mercenarios como
garantía de seguridad para el régimen gobernante
de turno; el político, mediante campañas
de propaganda y desinformación e incluso
organizando grupos falsos de observadores
electorales como los de la asociación AFRIC,
que actuaron en votaciones de países diversos
como Zimbabue, Madagascar, el Congo, Sudáfrica
y Mozambique.
Finalmente está el elemento económico: la
recompensa que estos Estados ofrecen a Wagner
por sus servicios.)
Pero esperad un momento, amigos, porque si
hay un lugar en el mundo donde los tentáculos
del grupo Wagner se han extendido hasta extremos
insospechados, ese país no es otro que la
República Centroafricana.
Su presidente,
Faustin-Archange Touadéra, había sido primer
ministro del país entre 2008 y 2013, cuando
fue destituido.
Por eso, cuando se hizo con el poder al ganar
las elecciones presidenciales de 2016, Touadéra
debió prometerse a sí mismo que jamás nadie
más le destituiría, ni siquiera el pueblo
centroafricano.
[Ya sabéis, una cosa es ganar las elecciones
y otra muy distinta arriesgarse a perderlas.]
Así que en 2018 la República Centroafricana
y el Kremlin cerraron varios acuerdos bilaterales
para intercambiar oficialmente apoyo militar
y armas por concesiones mineras.
Entonces, un antiguo oficial de inteligencia
del ejército ruso, Valery Zakharov, pasó
a ser el asesor de Seguridad Nacional del
presidente Touadéra y los mercenarios de
Wagner pasaron a integrar su escolta personal.
Además, se estima que el grupo Wagner desplegó
hasta 2.600 combatientes cuando surgieron
en el país grupos rebeldes armados.
Desde entonces la influencia rusa ha llegado
a niveles insospechados.
(El idioma ruso será una materia obligatoria
en las universidades de la República Centroafricana.
RBC)
Por desgracia para la República Centroafricana,
uno de los países más pobres del mundo,
el cultural no es el único peaje que están
pagando a Rusia.
La estabilidad del presidente Touadéra en
el poder tiene un precio y este no es precisamente
barato.
La República Centroafricana ha puesto sus
recursos naturales a disposición de Wagner.
¿Queréis saber cómo de rentable puede ser
convertirse en el dueño de un ejército de
mercenarios?
Pues…
Atentos.
T2 (EL ORO DE MOSCÚ)
Una cosa es que Vladimir Putin se haya vengado
de Prigozhin y otra muy distinta es que esté
dispuesto a renunciar a todo lo que los Wagner
están logrando para Rusia, que es mucho.
África es ahora mismo clave para el Kremlin.
Es vital para demostrar que Rusia no se ha
quedado aislada, tal y como trató de exhibir
con la cumbre celebrada con altos mandatarios
del continente a finales de julio en San Petersburgo.
Y todo lo que Wagner ha conseguido en África
ha tenido un gran impacto a bajo coste.
Por ejemplo, en los países en los que opera,
está ayudando a expandir los mensajes antioccidentales.
Y las conexiones de Wagner con los caudillos
africanos pueden convertirse a futuro en una
influencia que mejore las relaciones oficiales
de estos Estados con la propia Rusia.
Además, qué demonios, los mercenarios rusos
entre manos, tienen proyectos demasiado fructíferos
como para renunciar a ellos.
Se llama capitalismo a la rusa, amigos.
(La República Centroafricana ha otorgado
concesiones mineras de oro y diamantes a empresas
vinculadas al Grupo Wagner como Midas Resources.
Entre estos activos se encuentra la mina Ndassima.
Tiene reservas de oro por valor de más de
mil millones de dólares y los mercenarios
podrán explotarla durante 25 años.
Bois Rouge, otra empresa vinculada a Prigozhin,
recibió la concesión para talar diversos
bosques tropicales vírgenes, dando al Grupo
Wagner una nueva oportunidad de negocio de
gran potencial: la industria maderera.)
Los cientos de empresas fachada del Grupo
Wagner son fundamentales en la estrategia
del Kremlin para ganar aliados en África,
al mismo tiempo que Rusia se apodera de sus
recursos y encuentra nuevas formas de evadir
las sanciones occidentales.
Entre todos estos recursos destaca el oro.
La República Centroafricana, pero también
otros países como Sudán, están siendo una
fuente de oro vital para el Kremlin, puesto
que las reservas de oro ayudan a Rusia a resistir
el impacto de las sanciones por la guerra
de Ucrania.
De esta forma, el oro africano llega a Moscú
haciendo frecuentemente la misma escala: Emiratos
Árabes Unidos.
Y a pesar de las sanciones impuestas por Occidente,
el flujo de oro hacia Rusia continúa.
Según sus propios datos, las reservas de
oro rusas han aumentado durante el último
año.
Han alcanzado, de hecho, un máximo histórico
en 2023, tal y como podéis ver en el siguiente
gráfico que recoge los datos trimestrales
de las reservas de oro rusas por toneladas
durante las últimas dos décadas.
Además, un informe del Parlamento británico
señaló hace dos meses que el contrabando
de oro estaba contribuyendo a sostener la
economía rusa.
Pues bien, mientras tanto, el método Wagner
continúa cosechando éxitos y demostrando
que es buna máquina de hacer dinero.
¿Otro ejemplo concreto?
Pues fijaos, en Malí, donde gobierna una
junta militar después de dos golpes de Estado
en los últimos años, todas las informaciones
apuntan a que el Grupo Wagner está cobrando
una tarifa mensual de 10 millones de euros.
Vamos, ni Messi en el Inter de Miami.
El objetivo de los mercenarios rusos en Malí
es luchar contra grupos yihadistas asociados
a Al-Qaeda y al Daesh.
Para ello hay sobre el terreno unos 1.600
efectivos de Wagner y la junta militar de
Malí debe estar encantada con su trabajo
a la vista de que expulsaron del país a las
tropas francesas y ahora se van a marchar
los 13.000 cascos azules de la ONU después
de exigírselo el propio Gobierno maliense.
La junta militar ya ha elegido su reemplazo.
(La ONU pone fin a la misión de mantenimiento
de la paz en Mali y el Grupo Wagner se dispone
a llenar el vacío.
Bloomberg)
Previamente, un informe de la ONU había acusado
a las tropas malienses y a los mercenarios
rusos de matar a más de 500 personas durante
una operación militar en marzo de 2022.
Y claro, sentirse vigilados es algo que incomoda
y mucho a las dictaduras.
Mucho mejor trabajar con Wagner.
Algo así debió de pensar el propio Vladímir
Putin cuando la población rusa mostró su
incomodidad ante la movilización parcial
para la guerra en Ucrania.
Ahora bien, después de años operando bajo
las sombras, el presidente ruso quiso restar
méritos a Prigozhin a raíz de su motín
y admitió que, detrás de toda la parafernalia
del grupo Wagner, al final de todo estaba
el propio Estado ruso.
El mantenimiento de todo el grupo Wagner corrió
a cargo del Estado.
Del Ministerio de Defensa, del presupuesto
estatal, financiamos íntegramente este grupo.
Sólo de mayo 2022 a mayo 2023 el Estado pagó
al grupo Wagner en concepto de salarios e
incentivos 86.262 millones de rublos.)
Estamos hablando de más de 800 millones de
euros en un solo año.
Vamos, que salen más caros que el aceite
de oliva.
Ahora bien, dado que el problema para el Kremlin
ha sido la creciente ambición de Prigozhin,
reemplazar al grupo Wagner o bien integrarlo
en otras compañías militares privadas de
otros oligarcas debería ser relativamente
sencillo para los responsables de la Defensa
rusa.
Y teniendo eso en cuenta, la pregunta es evidente.
¿Por quién?
Y esta vez con una segunda cuestión añadida:
¿Qué rol están dispuestos a adoptar los
actuales dirigentes de Wagner?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T3 (EL OCASO DE LOS DIOSES)
El Grupo Wagner quedó completamente descabezado
el pasado 23 de agosto.
Aquel día murió Prigozhin, pero también
sus dos colaboradores más cercanos: su mano
derecha Dmitry Utkin, alias Wagner, así como
Valery Chekalov, el responsable de toda la
logística del grupo Wagner.
Tal vez su suerte habría sido otra si Prigozhin
se hubiera amoldado a los planes de Putin.
Las fechas son importantes en esta secuencia
de los hechos.
El motín fallido se produjo los días 23
y 24 de junio.
Luego, el día 29, en el encuentro que tuvieron
en el Kremlin, Putin sugirió que el antiguo
coronel Andrey Troshev debía ser el nuevo
líder de Wagner.
Prigozhin se negó y optó por llevarse sus
mercenarios a Bielorrusia.
Incluso aumentó su afrenta a Putin expulsando
a Troshev de Wagner el 30 de junio.
(El Grupo Wagner despide a uno de sus cinco
líderes: un ex coronel del ejército ruso.
Newsweek)
Diversas informaciones indican que Troshev
se negó a participar en el motín de Wagner
e incluso señalan que avisó al Kremlin de
la rebelión que estaba cocinando Prigozhin.
Troshev es un coronel retirado, veterano de
la invasión soviética de Afganistán y de
las guerras rusas en Chechenia.
Al parecer se había convertido en el hombre
de confianza de Prigozhin en Siria.
Y ahora Putin quería recompensar su lealtad
otorgándole el liderazgo del grupo de mercenarios
como si Wagner fuera una empresa estatal más.
Pero, a la hora de la verdad, no pudo imponer
su decisión.
No obstante, es un tipo de información que
tampoco debemos descartar que el Kremlin sea
el principal interesado en divulgar.
(Que el Kremlin exhiba la capacidad de nombrar
al jefe del Grupo Wagner es una opción poco
conveniente, sobre todo después de reconocer
que lo financia el presupuesto estatal.
Nacionalizar al Grupo Wagner no es interesante
ni para la propia Rusia, que no podría negar
su implicación en las atrocidades cometidas
por Wagner, ni tampoco para los Gobiernos
africanos, que tienen más fácil argumentar
que el país está bajo su control si lo que
contratan son mercenarios en lugar de fuerzas
que responden directamente ante las autoridades
de Estados extranjeros.)
Por este motivo, parece sensato pensar que
al Kremlin le interesaría más un Grupo Wagner
más parecido al de sus orígenes: un grupo
de mercenarios sobre el que circulan muchos
rumores y pocas certezas.
Un regreso a las sombras con el que recuperar
la negación verosímil.
En este caso, los actuales mercenarios de
Wagner pueden ser contratados por otra compañía
militar privada y sus operaciones globales
continuar bajo un liderazgo más favorable
al Ministerio de Defensa ruso.
Y aquí es donde vuelve a cobrar relevancia
la figura del coronel Troshev.
Acaba de encontrar trabajo y nos ha colocado
sobre la pista de quién podría heredar el
imperio creado por Prigozhin, Utkin y Chekalov
(¡Fuera Wagner, entra Redut!
¿Surge una nueva empresa militar privada
en Rusia bajo el control directo del Kremlin?.
EuroAsiaTimes)
De Redut se sabe que trabajó en la seguridad
de proyectos de infraestructura en Siria dirigidos
por Stroytransgaz, una empresa de ingeniería
vinculada al sector petrolero y gasístico
controlada por el Grupo Volga del oligarca
Gennady Timchenko.
También que después de contratar a Troshev,
Redut está tratando de reclutar personal
de Wagner y combatientes con experiencia para
luchar en Ucrania.
Y podrían expandirse próximamente al continente
africano ya que, si eres un líder africano
que necesita hombres armados, lo que menos
te importa es si su insignia pone Redut o
Wagner.
Algo así ya expresó a finales de junio un
alto cargo del Gobierno de la República Centroafricana
en declaraciones a la agencia AFP.
(La República Centroafricana firmó un acuerdo
de defensa con la Federación Rusa y no con
Wagner.
Rusia ha subcontratado a Wagner; si Rusia
ya no está de acuerdo con Wagner, entonces
nos enviará un nuevo contingente.
Fidèle Gouandjika, ministro asesor especial
del presidente centroafricano.)
Reemplazar a Wagner por Redut garantizaría
a Rusia mantener el control de las minas y
los recursos naturales que están en manos
de los mercenarios rusos.
Pero esperad un momento amigos, porque el
Grupo Wagner no ha dicho aún su última palabra.
Todavía hay un grupo de irreductibles que
se plantea vengar la muerte de Prigozhin y
acaba de elegir un nuevo líder.
(Se destapa el nuevo señor de la guerra del
Grupo Wagner al asumir 'Lotus' el cargo de
jefe mercenario: Express)
Lotus es como llaman a Anton Yelizarov, también
conocido como “El conquistador de Soledar”.
Se trata de un fiel colaborador de Prigozhin
en los escenarios más complicados como Siria
o Ucrania.
Pero hay que ser realistas.
Lo más probable es que los mercenarios de
Wagner se inclinen más por garantizar su
propia supervivencia antes que por desafiar
a Putin permaneciendo leales a un líder muerto.
Pero ahora la pregunta es para todos vosotros.
¿Creéis que Redut será una compañía militar
privada tan exitosa como la construida por
Prigozhin?
¿O pensáis que optará por un perfil más
discreto como el de los orígenes del Grupo
Wagner?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, si te ha resultado interesante
el vídeo dale a like y no olvides suscribirte
a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.